good morning everyone happy Friday
welcome back to the morning toast we I
am here with a honor to have you here
like I've literally been looking forward
to this all week I woke up this morning
you know how something's just like wake
you up right so like I only had to
snooze twice because I was like
Heather's coming on the toast like let's
do this yes and I leave like pep in my
step of course it takes me 45 minutes to
get here and now I'm out of breath and
disheveled but you're here well you look
stunning you're glowing
thank you and I feel like I got here
yesterday and literally I've just been
sweating since I landed in New York and
I'm from Atlanta so I'm used to that
like steam heat I had almost like a
nervous breakdown at Lord & Taylor
yesterday like I showed up walked into
the jewelry jewelry department because
like Lord & Taylor's like my Mecca it's
just we're like right it's clothing I
can't really discuss it the Fifth Avenue
flagship is closing cuz we were just
coming in I get it you have to do your
startup but I like live on the second
floor we story about we work today some
excited to get into it to rip into them
yes yes absolutely so I was just
sweating and like my usual lady in the
jewelry department was like haven't seen
you in a moment do you need a water like
you know it's bad when at Lord and
Taylor they ask you to need a
refreshment
because I was just having a hot flash
breaking down is like it's too hot out
here so but I'm glad to be here you know
it's hot like even though Atlanta
probably is like hotter right you guys
get like shade and trees and maybe a
breeze like we got concrete tall
buildings no straws no truck you're
really taking the water war on straws
seriously okay here's the deal
so like a month ago I was just like on a
walk going to Starbucks doing my daily
like morning routine and I just have it
like an epiphany I'm like wait a minute
why does Starbucks still use drawers
okay now I'm not like a huge
environmentalist but I was like this is
the smallest thing that you change so I
mentioned it literally like a week later
to the moment Starbucks announced that
in 2020 they're getting rid of straws so
I ordered all these medals trials of
course today I forgot my damn metal
straw and so I was just like well now I
can't go back you know what I mean you
know no you can't especially as someone
who like advocated for right the removal
of straws because I'm on the other end
of the spectrum because yes I was like a
small thing we could change and like the
turtles
it's really sad but now I've been
cutting up my straws before I throw them
away so I feel like that that's
compromise right but like when you see
the stats like straws account for such
so little right of the plastic in the
ocean then maybe we can make like bigger
changes first and also I just like don't
like adrian grenier and knowing he was
behind yes yes but actually now this
makes me feel better cuz it makes me
feel like you might have been behind
this with your one Instagram story
literally my one insight i just want to
say that like i'm an influencer and my
one Instagram story is starting to
change lives I believe like I can
manifest for the universe and other
people but not necessarily for myself so
I was just putting it out there and good
jet it was a week later they're like
we're cutting straws and here's the
thing but now like once you commit you
can't go back now I acted like you just
don't even realize getting a straws in
your day to day just like the minutia of
like how you work and I you just don't
even think about it and I got a straw at
a restaurant and somebody like ripped
into me and they're like Yuri anti straw
is how could you do this I mean I didn't
even think about it
so now I made a conscious effort to
bring my metal straws around but I have
like six Aperol spritz is last night so
it's just like it's yeah I forgot it you
know I have a couple questions you know
you're your mobile metal straw first of
all I love a metal straw it's the
tastiest thing in the world it keeps
your drink super cold super cold that's
why I love it there's nothing worse than
a paper straw Oh like I wanted
disintegrates in your mouth it like
makes me gag it's disgusting yeah okay
but here's my question up metal stress
okay how do you wash it how do you put
in your purse like when it's wet after
you drank your eyebrows print great
questions so you just blow it like
you're blowing like a blow dart just get
all the liquid out and then I have this
little like scrubber if you will and you
just clean it rinse it with water I have
in a little carrying case I'm so pissed
that I forgot it cuz I could change the
world you really could oh but yeah it's
great that the just the the washing and
the wetness and the like ensuing I would
assume like smelliness is what I can use
telling it no smelling it yeah here's
the fit now okay
by the guy who does my Botox I do like
baby Botox you know cuz I'm 31 and like
living my truth I do Botox
I just got it for the first time and
like I said in nightmare the other night
that it was fading when you wake up and
you're like no no no I see like I can
move my eyes now as an actress I have to
be able to move my face okay so I can
totally move my face but I just do the
smallest cuz this right here like that's
what I did it went and she went I'm
doing my whole forehead they all do that
I can still good that's the only that's
the only movement I need see I have to
still be able to do a resting [ __ ]
and like throw shade you know from
across the room when I need to but my
doctor said he was like actually straws
are terrible for you
you're better off just whitening your
teeth like all the time because straws
will give you the worse wrinkles here
right it's worse than like smoking a
cigarette really yeah
and then you know people get on to
they're like oh you shouldn't use a
plastic top which when I go to Starbucks
I ask for like no top but then it gets
messy so either commit to like not using
a straw or commit to like a metal straw
I don't know pick one I can't win no
like a golden retriever okay it'll
probably like work out my abs or
something it's insane you can't win no
you truly can't win but I appreciate
your commitment and thank you to the
anti strong movement I'll find other
ways to help the environment I love that
you know what at least you're like
putting it out there in the universe
yeah also I get really stressed out when
I go to Whole Foods and you know you've
got the compost and the recycling I will
read those like what it says on the bins
14 times I'm still like is this compost
like I have to take a moment be like is
this paper I just shut down when it
comes to recycling right and like
there's recycling general but then
sometimes they divide it paper plastic
glass and I don't know if I can what
happens if I put them together it's this
stressful process right is somebody
gonna chase you out of the store like
what part of the day or you're gonna
ruin somebody at like the recycling
plants situation no totally and because
like you really I really do care because
it's it's so sad once I'm gonna psych go
into the plastic and take out trash from
it or go into the trash and take out
plastic from it I want to make that
person's job easier I really do but it's
very confusing it's very confusing but
you know what either just just don't do
the plastic straw I mean at this point
I'm like I'm doing the most in the wheel
at the same time you know I'm just gonna
oh this is your moment you're affecting
change I'm effecting change I'm gonna
drag influencer at thirty-one
put the Shah in the drink so it's usin
now that's okay that's okay and I'll try
and figure out how we should like
properly dispose of these you know what
the reason why I have to use a straw is
because I have a slurping problem oh
that's okay I don't know how to drink
from a cup without slurping also you're
right
reminds me of that yes and video that
you did I'm obsessed with me ASMR also
my mom keeps telling everybody's like
watch my daughter's a s my Q like a s
literally she's told people that I have
like some weird sex thing that I do
online cuz you can't pronounce it what
is ASMR stand for again I don't really
know what's like audio stimulation
manual response that's not that's not
correct
no Claudia's obsessed with ASMR and
usually it doesn't do it for me but
you're a smart was really good thank you
like I watched a bunch of videos okay
one of my girlfriend's was like you
either have it you either have that
little tic in your brain that that it
relaxes you or it's like nails on a
chalkboard
and for me listen to somebody crunch or
whisper or crinkle soap I can't hear me
that's cringe cringe hills shivers down
my sign okay so I became familiar with
your work because you championed a very
an important cause yes
affectionately called brittany 9-1-1
brittany 9-1-1 we must save her we must
save her so she's been in the news a lot
lately and I think that's how someone
introduced me to your video and I
watched your whole story and I was like
yes like this is it like there's
something going on with Brittany but I
couldn't articulate without because I
don't know anything about her and like I
didn't want to be rude but you're you
have a theory about Brittany okay it all
started about three weeks ago I woke up
on a Sunday super hungover and you know
when you're hungover and you just feel
like you need to project into the
universe and you're like I need to like
I don't know now my 30s when I'm
hungover I just really want like such
anxiety you know could you get bounced
back no kids the moral hangover for me
is like now worse than the physical a
hundred percent so I just I was like
scrolling through Instagram and I said
okay that's it
time's up we must discuss why is why are
we just all like commenting on Britney
Spears is Instagram acting like this is
normal behavior
you know she's posting a lot of weird
stuff that just to me behind the eyes so
much
changed since even a year ago two years
ago I mean the fashion runway videos
that she does and her giant mansion and
Thousand Oaks you know - like crappy
music and then she's got the bad
extension she just to me it's like she
is obviously in charge of her own
Instagram account that's the one thing
that they will allow her to have control
over totally and it's a cry for help
and so I just like like randomly was
like is it are we gonna talk about this
and it went viral because I think
everyone was like we've been thinking in
but you can't say it you can't say
you're saying it at a place of love
concern and you're a big Britney fan
huge Britney fan and I'm from the south
you know Britney was like our champion I
remember I had a family friend that
worked in the music business and I got
to hear her first hit when I was like 15
and I heard it before a lot of people
and I look to my mother as a mom she's
gonna be a star and I just knew like I
knew it was gonna happen I think I may
have manifested all this before
correctly yeah and I just knew was gonna
have it but it is just crazy and people
have been sending me inside scoops on on
her like people who worked for her or
worked in the hotel for her residency
yeah they're sending me some some dirt
interesting cuz my my thought has always
been like clearly she doesn't enjoy like
the performing anymore she doesn't do
much she's lip-syncing she's barely
dancing we'll get to the Britney
challenge in a little bit why won't they
just let her retire like and retire as
an icon as opposed to like a sad lip
syncher I think is the the train got so
far off the track a couple years ago and
I think they really just want to like
salvage that reputation but okay one of
the biggest things that I noticed you
know she's on tour right now in Europe
well the European fans have been savage
they keep commenting she's phoning it in
what is she doing well wait a half-ounce
of choreography and I mean I I was even
like nervous to say something but so
many of Britney's fans responded to me
saying like oh no we agree something's
going on okay so I felt like I was in a
safe space to be like we're all
concerned about the same thing right so
then I noticed now that the European
fans are just like being savage like
this is crazy I can't believe I spent
money you know this much amount of money
to watch her phone it in right to your
question though to answer that she's got
too many people on the payroll you know
I think she lost all that money when she
had her
breakdown a couple years ago she's
trying to build it back up I think
she'll probably tour maybe for two more
years and then you know throw in the
towel she was too cheap she wants to
teach cheer sport and go to barbecues
back in Louisiana she doesn't need much
and so the people around her need to
hitch their ride to someone else's train
because like this train is a wreck yeah
so that would be my advice to Britney's
team and I'm sure they're watching this
because I'm sure they're keeping close
tabs on you do you ever feel like when
you start like talking conspiracy
I'm being watched we talk so much
conspiracy theory on this show but do
you ever be blind items yes I do
so we give voice to blind items a lot
crazy days and nights is our personal
favorite and like sometimes we catch
ourselves first of all we sounds so
crazy like do not want to look into this
we're talking about people who weren't
committed suicide or some say we're
murdered in Hollywood and like we're
talking about it right
and it's like okay they got murdered for
talking about it what do we think it's
gonna happen to us I've noticed that
things have been popping up on my
Instagram like I'm sure I'm sure I'm on
a list somewhere a written list pretty
much I'm on a Britney watch list and if
I got a you know brawl in the street
just to save my girl I'm gonna do it you
know why cuz I'm a Pisces and I'm
selfless okay speaking of horoscopes I
can watch I'm not big on horoscopes but
mostly because I don't feel like I
identify with mine okay what are you I'm
a Scorpio okay and I know like when I
say Scorpio people like oh so I know
like sport the reputation is like just
crazy passionate yes you said loyal
which I appreciated right like oil but
it's such a crazy right loyal to a fault
right um so like what would you say
overall it's like a good description of
a Scorpio that I can like make peace
with um okay Scorpios make the absolute
best friends they're the kind of friends
legit Scorpios are the kind of people
that will stick through you no matter
what now they're sometimes the friends
were you like okay Karen you can you
know you're right on me you can take a
step back I'm good
why are you crying do you cry a lot a
little emotionally sometimes you know
yeah like I'm either here or I'm here
like I'm not just
like that fair enough I mean we all are
you know just trying to get through the
day but yeah Scorpios love hard but with
that when they get hurt
it's like watch out yeah yeah okay now
listen here's a thing I'm not really
into the horoscopes either I just found
out that like I could start to kind of
read people when somebody would said
that whenever I'd meet something they're
like oh I'm a Taurus I'm like of course
you are you know I just have bad people
tortoises tourists gay men I thrive with
tar what's Taurus month like Taurus
month is end of April through the
beginning of May okay so my my fiance's
a Taurus
okay but your Scorpio so you're good
okay yeah yeah what are you high seas
okay yes I'm in love with a Virgo so
don't panic it's gonna work out okay I
think it's time to get into the past I
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast and our little sound
graphic and then we're gonna do our Q&A
with Heather we have all of your
questions waiting for her the podcast
the Britney challenge etc your mom on
bumble I'm literally like cleaning up
doing it here in New York well your mom
went live on Instagram last night he
didn't get a chance to watch yeah and
one of the toasters was telling me she
was giving some some very sound advice
to women and how to keep a man and her
number one piece of advice is to get a
housekeeper cuz your man does not want
to see you like over the toilet
scrubbing well it's just that not only
that but also she was just like you
don't ask your man if he's going out
there and slaying dragons and working
his ass off all day he doesn't need to
come home and then also be expected to
do chores and my mom is very feminist
like I am woman hear me roar if you have
a career great which is like just make
it easier on everybody and just get the
help that you need and you can afford it
I mean look I you know just to some
somebody to come once a month just to do
that deep clean and never leave dirty
dishes in the sink ladies I'm sorry yeah
that just shouldn't yeah then they start
to smell I can't deal with with smells
right you know that's my number one
thing and I think I need to get a bigger
trash can because like we're taking out
the trash once a day now and we don't
make that much trash so I think I think
that would be like a good step I think
it's a great step you know and I don't
like take like if I like I don't mind
doing the dishes beg really don't like
take out the trash I go into the trash
after like it smells I always have to
like come back wash my hands right and
then again you have like a hot flash
next to the trash compactor cause you're
like is this recycling it's a sign it's
packed like the whole foods thing right
like to my jewelry fall off and go down
the chute anxiety I can't I always have
my cell phone in my hand when I'm
opening it I'm like I'm literally living
on the edge you're asking I'm asking for
it you're asking for it once I might
accidentally threw out a pair of
sunglasses in the trash compactor and I
went down there to look for them and I
went through the trash they were saline
it was worth it and I did not find them
so it wasn't worth it
that's why I only buy cheap sunglasses
now no totally actually they were a gift
so like me like it wasn't my thumb right
but they really looked they looked
expensive you know it was I think they
were worth it yeah I would go through
the trash for like obviously a couple
cheap things like hey this much shirt
from Old Navy that I'm obsessed with and
I'm headed for three years I'd probably
dumpster dive for it yeah yeah and also
I had to go through the trash just to
say that I did not that I just was
someone who threw away a pair of Slean
sunglasses and never looked back
great I don't want to be that person
right anyways our first story are about
a group of women who would definitely
throw out a pair of Sweden sunglasses
and never look back they throw him in
somebody's face totally like the card
Jenner sisters celebrated Kylie's
birthday last night 21 I'm so excited
for her to be 21 like - and they went to
my favorite place in Los Angeles they
went to Craig I've never been there okay
it is a scene it's like a mixture of you
know the real housewives and then just
create hookers and I have been somebody
thought I was a hooker there once just
because I think I'm like 510 and blond
and I give off like a strong but you but
you're great a then if you're a hooker
at Craigs
yes exact so that's actually a
compliment yes I like to sit at the bar
I get the half spaghetti bolognaise you
can do a half portion to die for they
actually have one of the best vegan like
chicken parms you've ever had in your
life but it is great people-watching
it's a whole situation I'm like Chris
goes there a lot called it once when and
she saw Chris and she was like Whitney
was past her and I just can't I love him
I love him but I'm also
katharine mcphee yeah she's ruining him
ruining because like he could he's such
a great guy and in like David versus or
Lana I'm totally team David yes that's a
tricky situation even though the lemons
on my dress would make you think I'm
team Yolanda
not I mean she had a lemon a full lemon
garden overlooking like that that goes
sad house was goals goals adding it to
the board add it to the boards like they
had things in their home that you don't
you can't even like dream up the
see-through fridge although that would
stress me out they always had a lot of
fruit like a lot of put are you eating
that much fruit they definitely have
like the see-through fridge and then
like a fridge in the garage that's like
the real food right with the snapples on
the coke zeros like oh yeah yeah for
sure anyways the car Jenner celebrated
Kylie's birthday at Craigs so when there
was a big ball pit that looks like a
home yes that was a side they went to
dinner at Craigs like a family dinner
and then I think they had a house party
yes and it looked so lit the girls
looked amazing nothing makes me happier
than when they're all together and
honestly the color scheme and then you
had Kendall coming out like that I am
woman hear me roar just black leather
number yeah everybody was in like a pink
and a pastel and when Kim wears a pink
you know that Kanye like doesn't allow
her to wear a pink so the fact that she
showed up in a neon number live your
truth honey yes I'll say it from the top
of the Hollywood Hills where that pink
where that picture looks great
fantastic row pink by the way Kylie was
wearing pink - just like they each look
their best we do and they seem their
best you know everything except for
Courtney's going through a breakup right
now but I think it's not it's like a
good breakup I am so on board for this
breakup right and they were sitting next
to each other at dinner Scott and
Courtney yes and who was it was a Chloe
or was it yeah oh I want them to get
back together like married couple of
their couples they gonna end up together
we already know this do you think
they'll have another kid I could see
that me too absolutely I could see that
and I mean I have a big heart for Scott
I really do you know I think we've all
gone through this like rollercoaster
ride of Scott and his emotions at his
behavior but you know what it's just cuz
if I was an outsider coming into that
family I probably be speedballing you
know drinking vodka every night just
trying to like keep up you're literally
keeping up with the kardashians
literally like there was a time
in the early days when he was like
punching mirrors in Miami and I was like
why do you keep this guy around like
he's trouble he really tried to better
himself and then he lost both of his
parents and like I just I can't and he
has no one except for these girls who
like he can't even count on because he's
always with Courtney so I just I really
feel for him but I love that like Chris
like keeps him in the inner circle and I
feel like he's okay I think he's okay
now too and I feel like Sofia isn't the
worst choice for him no I think that she
was familiar you know they all grew up
with her I mean the age difference
whatever my mom was 11 years older than
my late father so I am all about like
date younger older it doesn't matter
right if you'd found a good person
agreed um no I I like Sofia in the mix
but she's it's it's gonna last another
what three days until until they get
back together
well I'm gallant and then I really feel
like that would complete the circle you
know I mean except Kendall is like
single but she's like living the dream
right so but everyone else is kind of
like settling down and we're like
they're at the prime of their careers
and like the prime of their personal
lives but you don't get to see quite
often you never get to see that and I
have to apologize like I know Chloe
doesn't know this but I just feel like I
need to get it off my chest I was so
upset about the Tristan Chloe situation
and I realized you know when at the end
of the day yes we all judge from afar
but we don't know what's going on and I
want them to make it work and he has had
to eat humble pie and I really I want to
see family units yeah I want to see it
work I want them to just make it happen
and I want to see Kourtney and Scott so
Chloe I apologize I think she forgives
you thank you
I just needed to hear that no I agree I
just was so upset interesting like I I
imagine that he cheats on her but really
for him to do it so publicly and like
embarrass her like that pregnant like
have a little discretion right like you
know you want but like come on it just
makes guys would be smarter you would
you really you're in the national
television on such a large platform
you're not gonna be a little bit a
little bit like shady or a little bit
paranoid I'm paranoid and I'm paranoid
about the friggin straws okay
one person sent me a message like you're
a [ __ ] you forgot about the straws and
it like shook me to my core I wasn't
right for three days
so you know if I can't handle the straws
I can't I couldn't also this past week
of Kardashian's the fight the Kim
Kourtney fight it triggered something
within my own family no seat because you
have a sister I do yes and I'm we're one
of Claudia and I are sisters and two
other sisters so like that was so real
I actually I mean we know Mercury's in
retrograde it's like not even in this
solar system and I was PMS saying and I
called my sister the next day and
started like a World War 3 fight with
her
I'm just watching that and I kind of
respond like Kim does but I'm also
sensitive good love the baby and we just
like we literally got into it because I
was just triggered by the whole
situation but there are things that we
need to clear up and now we're all great
but that was really moving and I had so
many people send me messages saying they
found the same way they were triggered
by the whole situation whose side were
you on
I was on Kim's side okay but I also had
empathy for Kourtney I just felt that
Kourtney has always been stirring the
pot and kind of been a [ __ ] since day
one right now like I'm just can't with
her sometimes but I mean Kim was very
savage and y'all talked about it the
other day that you're so surprised there
that savage to each other on national
television they have the choice to air
that or not exact but I guess because it
happened so long ago they know it makes
it interesting that happened over so
they're past it and then like we all are
watching we're still talking about it's
been a week right it's the most
interesting to have a thing to happen on
the show like in so long and you know
whatever Kourtney wants to be a mom I
think that's fantastic you do you but I
agree with everything they all said the
other day it's just like alright you're
on this train it's leaving the station
totally it's going straight to Ryan
Crespi you know Ryan Seacrest Bakke
account so and all they do is like show
up to eat a salad
take a picture eat a high nut salad
drink your iced tea super slowly take a
picture in some Levi's and then cash
your checks we'll see yeah
I can't imagine it's so hard anyways
that they all enjoyed the fruits of
their labor last night and I just like I
think a really good life goal for me is
like to one day hope to be invited to
like just one Kardashian party even if
it's like Easter
something random like a beauty launch
right like a President's Day barbecue
okay nothing even like so crazy doesn't
have to be Kylie's 21st like I
understand that's a big deal but just
one small thing I feel like I would
really buy with Kris Jenner because Kris
Jenner is very similar to my mom savage
and I just you know everyone gives Chris
so much [ __ ] but I I would want to go to
lunch with Chris before I'd want to go
to lunch with anybody else no she's
really coming up it's like everyone's
favorite Kardashian because she we like
she admits she drinks vodka on the rocks
all day and I would too if I had to get
through that totally and that's why she
and Scott are like buddies you know
they're like you want to have a cocktail
you see these [ __ ] and we're dealing
with yeah what's crazy is that the girls
don't really drink they don't well you
know Kim doesn't drink because Kim and
her exercises it makes me sweat I wait
got that like 9:30 and I see that she's
been up since like 3:30 in the morning
doing fundamentals week like do in her
arms and abs and I just dress I go to
Barry's boot camp five days a week and
you cannot tell so I don't know what I
don't know what I'm doing five days a
week I'm doing the most and seeing the
least results I've never been to Barry's
I'm like one time I booked a class and I
had to cancel because I was like so
nervous I'm nervous I do it all the time
and I do SoulCycle I do all of it I
still get nervous go into a new place
for the first time is so nerve-racking
like you don't know like the traffic
patterns of the locker room I'm like
where to put yourself where to studio is
and like once you do it one time like
it's fine but getting over that like
first time hump
all right I've got to do that and I'm
trying to I'm trying to do that with
Rumble also I haven't been for one spoke
to class got too drunk different the
last thing I could kickboxing and just
boxing in general is actually the
hardest thing I've never been so winded
in my life than when I took a rumble
class so I will I will say never you
need to not only stay so hydrated like
you need to prepare for that like you're
doing the New York City Marathon to take
your class like 9:00 a.m. oh yeah okay
I'm gonna do it just cuz I got to switch
it up I've been doing SoulCycle for
years and like my body it's like we
enjoy it now it's like fun but I reckon
changing I feel things changing you know
you got a cross train you know I worked
for SoulCycle
you did yes I worked the front desk in
West Hollywood when I first moved to LA
one of my girlfriend's ran all the
studios and she's like you know we need
you to come and like be able to talk to
celebrities and not be a creep and I
said great I'm your girl
I got in trouble because I would I was
in the best shape of my life when I
worked there cuz I bribed like twice a
day but I was eating Chipotle like just
a full burrito bowl at the front desk
and people were coming in to check in
like walk all over my face you're like
Heather this isn't on brand can you can
you take your snacks in the back yeah so
that's me do you ever see the movie I
feel pretty of course yeah we were
thoughts on it cuz I loved it and it's
very SoulCycle centric yes oh I
absolutely loved it busy and marker two
of my really good friends and here's the
thing I'm gonna say this I noticed that
she wore like the name plate necklace
and Amy Schumer
I had a moment where I was like that's
me at SoulCycle
oh I would say had like an outer-body I
was like that no her whole outfit is me
it SoulCycle and I met busy ex whole
cycle it's like I see the inspiration
there I was gonna say the name plate
necklace like she's wearing it when she
thinks she's Renee yeah hey and then
Renee so like she should have realized
oh my god he saw my necklace like the
end was like a little she dragged out
really stupid hurt with like the two
pictures and then realizing that she's
the same person yes they didn't they
didn't close the book as well as I would
have wanted but I I just loved I loved
the movie and I showed it to my mom the
other day and she like she was shipped
to her core she said Heather this was so
good and this I feel like it really
resonated with me because I have gone
through my life with like a just overly
confident so I spoke to Renee's
character because my mom was always like
you can do anything you want should just
go out there and like slay dragons and
don't take no for an answer don't take
anybody [ __ ] so when Amy Schumer was
stepping into that oh this is me like I
went to a modeling agency a couple years
ago luge it walked in it was like hi I'm
here I'm ready to work who wants to take
my photo and they were like ma'am it's
not today like you know we can we'll see
you out so I resonate with that
character no and so Claudia and I both
did but so Cudi's that exact same way as
you like confidence out the ass and then
I resonated with a two cuz like I should
like the past year I've definitely
gained weight and I'm just like not
feeling my best but it's like people see
you the way you see yourself and it's
like I was just getting so in my own
head I was a movie couldn't have come at
a better time for me personally cuz like
you are what you put out into the
universe and I just I love it so much
and it made me sad that like it was
well received totally I thought it was
really well received but then I know
that Amy Schumer had to kind of come
back cuz people are upset that like she
was the face of like not feeling pretty
but I'm like she's a normal sized woman
in Hollywood can I tell you some of the
auditions that I have gone on and the
breakdowns I went on and on additional
ones that that morbidly obese but
beautiful I'm gonna look right at the
camera excuse me you know like that kind
of stuff that's the breakdown like great
I have a pretty face but like from the
neck down we should just you know put a
sheet over me so I I you know I felt bad
that people some people got upset with
that but I thought the movie was
fantastic I thought it is exactly what
women need to hear right now I loved it
every second of it it was funny as [ __ ]
in that good heart
agreed do you know that was sponsored by
SoulCycle um I actually don't but Angela
Manuel Davis who was the instructor in
the movie she was one of my favorites
and I knew her well from West Hollywood
so I mean for SoulCycle to sign off on
something is a big deal totally it was
all like they were everywhere so you
would think that they paid for it but
then it's also like they would have made
sense as a choice regardless they don't
need ready for it well and busy and has
been such an advocate for SoulCycle and
that's where I actually met her and I
mean she's been like an OG day one so I
think there were men there they don't
sign off on a lot of things so I think
when they read the script they're like
absolutely we adore you she's the best
of course we're gonna sign off on this
speaking of busy she's getting a show on
E
so exciting what's your format do you
know um I don't know I haven't been told
the inside scoop yet but it's gonna be
amazing I don't know how many nights
it's gonna be on but I believe it comes
on after the Kardashians maybe so I mean
I'll be there already so I'll definitely
yeah busy tonight let's go honey make it
work yes it's gonna be awesome okay
next story Justin Bieber explains why he
was crying next to Haley Baldwin okay so
to speak some pictures emerged of Halley
and Justin like sitting on a street in
New York City like hysterically crying
like hands in head in hand that was me
yesterday I cried four times for no
reason I wasn't emotionally distraught
just shut down on the street or in the
home on the street on the street Lord
and Taylor I'm at lunch I'm just like
having a moment honestly it was the heat
it was the heat maybe that's why I like
day
into it - I feel like I'd only cry on
the street when like I can't get a cab
I'm carrying so many heavy things and
like I'm just like I can't even provide
for myself you know like I can't even
make it from point A to point B like
IKEA doing up but see I actually I tap
into beast mode I was like the son my
father never had so I've used to like
carrying a Crystal Springs water jug up
like three flights of stairs you know or
like unaware my dad like can you move
the baby grand piano from you know
downstairs of the Attic on a Tuesday so
when in that kind of situation when I
have to carry a lot of stuff and I'm
sweating like I thrive there but when I
putting on makeup gotten cute wearing it
like a sensible heel and then I'm
sweating that's when I start to shut
down oh I started to shut down when I
put on makeup
cute outfit sensible heel like so I
should be looking my best
mhm and I feel my worst and then I'm
like tearing through my closet like no
and that's when I break down but at
least it's in the privacy of my own home
right I mean I called my boyfriend reeks
like these - I called my boyfriend from
a dressing room the other day and we did
like nothing's working
and he is just he gets these phone calls
at least once a week I want to tell you
that's not you that's Bloomingdale's
because I have gone to Bloomingdale's so
many times in the past month right just
looking for anything like I need clothes
for the show and you closed for a night
I need clothes for vacation like I'll
take anything I need a jeans I need
shorts like I'm not being specific right
and I have not but in the past five
times I've gone there I've not bought
one thing like nothing is cute and it's
not you and it's them and they're
lighting and they're ugly [ __ ] I don't
know what it is about dressing room
lighting it's the worst and remember
when H&M trying to step up their game
and they had like like in some of the
fancy hnoms in the city you could have
like night lighting and day lighting it
still made me look horrible yeah and
they I can only really shop if you want
the best H&M if you're top-heavy like me
I'm very broad I could have been in the
NFL but I've got like a sensible skinny
ankle you know it all balances out I
consider myself an apple but if you want
a great hmm go to the hmm and Playa del
Carmen Mexico
I swear everything's made for like my
size Wow it's the best they had the best
stuff people will stop me in the street
and go where did you get that I said hmm
but in Mexico they have totally
different stuff than he
I mean I think so I go every Christmas
to stock up when I go to the H&M s in
Italy like when I'm vacationing I can't
fit into a single thing an extra-large
is like a two cuz Italians are small Wow
that is the best tip I got we've ever
received so these two were crying in the
street theories were brought up in
speculation with sprite amongst
followers of the famous couple as to
what could be the reasoning behind the
normal emotions okay ultimately the
Grammy winner assured fans that they
have nothing to worry about quote you've
got good days and you've got bad days
Justin told fans in a video obtained by
TMZ it's not real if it doesn't have any
bad days so they were also seen carrying
a book that said the meaning of marriage
while crying very poetic
no that's traumatic totally like if I
was crying at Lord & Taylor while
carrying a book that just said like how
to fit in these jeans you know a
magazine with a bag at the end of jeans
they're okay
they were like 14 years old I love Haley
I love Justin I love that he has found
the Lord because you know jesus is my
Lord and Savior as well I just feel that
they're too young to be getting married
let's just face the back you think so
absolutely how old is he he's like 20 oh
he's 24 well that's not so young it's
not so young but it's just I think I
don't know him so I can't like speak to
the level of his maturity right on the
one hand you think someone who grew up
so quickly in Hollywood at 24 has seen a
lot like Kylie I think is so mature
right she and I I think she's like ready
to be a mom and like because she could
just sit back and watch the mistakes of
all of her other sisters right so like I
feel like in some cases they grow up
quickly and they're mature in some cases
they never grow up right Britney Britney
so your official theory on Britney is
that I think that she as something
happened where she hasn't emotionally
she's she's regressed but she she hasn't
emotionally gotten there like she maybe
what is she 36 now I think but she still
has you know the thoughts of a 16 year
old
okay and this episode a lot of child
stars and there's just there's so many
puppet strings I think she's just got to
crank it out I think they want to keep
her working she's got a make up for all
the money that she lost when she was
going through the [ __ ] show of K
Federline you know he just
for more money yeah so I don't think she
has full custody of her sons Wow
or hehe no she has to share with him so
he's taking her money her dad's her
conservatorship but that just ended
you know she's got so many people on
that payroll it's lonely at the top I
totally agree
and she's got a crank it out and I never
want to speak on anyone's mental health
that's not what I'm here to do because
I'm such a fan of hers i I just feel
like if she's in control of her
Instagram or whoever is allowing her to
put this stuff up on her Instagram is
trying to send us a message as well and
message received message was saying how
do we help I have said that if you're
gonna spend the money to go to a
meet-and-greet the biggest thing is you
know people have gone to the meet and
greets any messages you know they brief
you for like an hour beforehand she's
very nervous she's very shy I think that
you need to just say Brittany thank you
so much she never gets think Brittany
thank you so much for making this
incredible music and being an
entertainer also like how are you doing
because people stand out they freak out
and I get it like I cried my eyes out
when I met Joan Rivers for the first
time like had an outer-body experience
but like I compose myself
and I thanked her and I feel like people
are in the entertainment business people
take take take from them and nobody ever
says thank you or nobody ever says like
I appreciate you it's always I want
something from you I wanted to do that
like come to come to Brazil exactly so I
think if we just take a moment and just
say are you okay
she nobody's probably asked her like
girl you good yeah I feelin yeah so the
fact that she's on tour right now with
pitbull has changed my life are you
gonna see them um I would love to go
check them out in Europe if he comes on
the tour back to America for sure just
side now if you've never been to a
pitbull concert it's it will change your
life really I'm a big pitbull not a big
people fan but I just I'd like him I
like his work I like his songs and I
feel like I should go to a show but I
never would have thought that everybody
is dressed to the nines I love that big
yes everyone is literally like decked
out looks fierce because you know he's
coming out in some fabulous white suit
so all the gentlemen that are there
trying to like step up their game oh
it's like when you dressed like the star
but usually it's Justin Bieber with the
flannel around his waist but instead I'm
in a suit it's incredible and you don't
realize that even if you only think you
know a couple of the songs from the
radio
you know every song you're not missing a
song so when I went my girlfriend bought
me tickets like on a whim she's like oh
my god let's go to people this will be a
riot and I do a big pitbull
impersonation because I'm obsessed with
him and I said this is honestly and
truly the best concert I've ever been to
Wow yes run don't walk to get the
tickets so he's with Brittany like that
just knocks to my head explodes two
birds one stone two birds one stone
I probably emotionally wouldn't be able
to handle like all of that greatness
under one roof no I understand okay
that's great to know
speaking of Brittany and her
conservatorship though another fallen
star amanda Bynes is looking forward to
her future despite extended
conservatorship reports
amanda Bynes conservatorship will be
extended until 2020 the actresses mother
Lynn Bynes will be responsible for the
former child stars decisions regarding
her mental and physical health according
to the blast the All That star was first
placed under a conservatorship in 2014
after a series of involuntary
psychiatric hold and multiple run-ins
with the police it was during one of her
mental one of her stays at a mental
health facility that the star was
diagnosed as bipolar with manic
depressive disorder however this is all
in the past
according to the family lawyer the
conservatorship can end at any time
prior to 2020 but both Amanda and her
parents on such good terms and happy
with Amanda's life and future the
conservatorship is the last thing on
their minds again Amanda when she went
off the deep end I think these kids it's
like throwing somebody into a crock-pot
right they have to be perfect and you
don't even get to make those mistakes
growing up so when they go to make that
mistake and rebel it's a [ __ ] show
right and then you add Dan shiner on top
of that I know legally I almost like I
don't want to speak about him only
because there's so much shady stuff
that's going on there and I just feel
like I'm not gonna speak on that but
you're you're smarter than we are
no it's just I don't know I don't know
no I I I know you know that you don't
know right you don't know and I just I'm
just ready for the coming of the dance
tiger like fur for the Harvey Weinstein
of Dan she's like I mean there's so many
of these people who have just taken
advantage of these kids and look my
sister was a child actress and I
commercials growing up and but my mom
was always like if this isn't fun if you
weren't enjoying this I mean we were
those theater nerds who like and I would
a theater camp for like eight weeks
every summer I this is what I love to do
but it was like if it wasn't fun then
we're not doing this and I just think
you know once these kids grow up in
front of the limelight that's so much
pressure and you're not allowed to even
have that moment where you're like 13
getting is it you know growing boobs and
get your period for the first time
yeah it's talked about on in Us Weekly
can you imagine if now I could imagine I
could not imagine you missing now as big
would fit I'm waiting for the day that I
do have that like next level of like
I've made it where TMZ catches me just
eating a sub sandwich but like a
footlong you know that's the way I
that's the way I go with my my hoagies
if you will and I'm just sitting in
sweats post SoulCycle just eaten a
sandwich like with my legs out just like
what's good you know right that's very
own brand for me though so right so it
would do well for you or going to be
crying in the street like dressing in
Haley that's not on bread for them like
if they're a whirlwind engagement like I
don't know and you know it was him
crying not her and she was controlling
him so he's an emotional guy he's in
touch with the Lord now I think he's
just like he's been very open and honest
about the better man that he is trying
to be do you think he's a better man no
cuz like there was a time when he was
such an animal like egging people's
homes I drag racing in the streets that
was immature like [ __ ] hookers in
South America do you think that we've
all been there haven't we you know we
all had a situation in Brazil that we
can't talk about so okay it's called my
late 20s I think it's there yeah I just
feel like Amanda mines is another one
like I hope they use this
conservatorship she just like easier
into normal life like she does not need
to work anymore I don't care about the
money like she can get a job and just
live her life because it's money - even
home what a mess
Oh left I don't know cuz when she was
being crazy like what she's spending all
of her money I don't she had that insane
apartment here in New York and she does
a lot of meth I think any [ __ ] she's
heading for the wedding shedding for the
wedding girl I know it's like it's oh
every day every
yeah I feel you I feel you um anyway so
even if it's like a money thing or not
about anything even though she should
have a good amount because like there
was a time when she was truly like for
kids like the biggest comic out there
like remember her on all that was she on
all that yeah yes
The Amanda Show hysterical hysterical
like the original SNL I may be just as
not for kids
yeah yeah man that [ __ ] things she
used to do with the holes in her teeth I
don't even know what that's called but
she was a pioneer for kids comedy I love
that I just said that amanda Bynes I
made a pioneer for kids coming in like
she's all that [ __ ] hysterical film
amazing but even like some of those kids
Kenan was the only one who got out of
that with a you know yeah I'm a high end
yeah and he's crushing it crushing it
and doesn't like get nearly enough shine
that he deserves he is just such a solid
just a staple at SNL he really is Agron
I don't always watch SNL and when I do I
don't always like it mm-hmm but any skit
that he's in like I'm crying when he
plays um Steve Harvey that speaks to my
soul that speaks to Who I am like I'd
love to listen to a Steve Harvey podcast
okay if you're having like a down day
tune into anything that Steve Harvey has
ever said into a microphone and it will
change your life really he's so
inspirational but like keeps it 100 and
keeps you grounded he really keeps it
100 because I really like him claudia
was on The Steve Harvey Show one's like
at the beginning of her career and like
he was just it was fabulous all around
and like I just I loved him but then she
say it was nice she did but he didn't
like he didn't really do anything other
than the show like there was another
height man who like got them all hyped
up right and he really was into her on
the show so then he was nice to her
afterwards but like I think he's like
very in and out well he also has like 45
different productions going on right he
does family feud he has like three radio
shows he's doing Miss America or Miss
Universe again and then he was on
comedians in cars getting coffee and
it's one of my favorite episodes but my
favorite and they were in Chicago yeah
smoking cigars like that was
conversational they're both just funny
people and
they were just keeping it so real and
being hilarious I couldn't agree more I
love I love that show
yeah we talk about it a lot I haven't
seen every episode but it really gives
you like a good sense like who's really
really funny
yeah who's just like awkward and like
just can deliver good jokes you know
absolutely and I just I'm telling you
right now go look at some of Steve
Harvey's really powerful moments I'm
sure there's so much on YouTube and
it'll just change your life some days
when I'm getting up I'm like I can't do
this I'm PMSing I'm you know I'm just
shutting down today I'll turn on my boy
Steve and I am filled with the Holy
Spirit
another amazing tip I'm really gonna do
that yeah okay this next story is about
we work you where Eddie shot on you this
morning we're taking over for Lord &
Taylor like I'm happy that small
businesses are expanding yes but at what
price at we work summer camp there's no
meat plastic straws or bottled water
okay this sounds treacherous environment
sustainability is a hot corporate trend
right now with one company after another
banning plastic straws offsetting carbon
emissions and taking other steps towards
being better planetary stewards but even
by that measure we work wants to be
outstanding in the field
literally some 8,000 we work employees
from around the world to send on a
bucolic pasture in England next week
whoever wrote this article like really
needs to be writing like novels for like
a wall street totally for the company's
seventh annual summer camp they'll
listen to talks from speakers like
entrepreneur and author Tim Ferriss
attend workshops and participate in
activities like stand-up paddleboard
Gong therapy and sound baths yes sound
dog therapy and sound baths you know
what's not really to try anything once
but but not dying Farabee I would is
gong therapy you know I know like but
what is it that's what I'm saying that's
what I'm saying to you also so I guess
we worked as a camp cool for them we
just announced that we're doing camp
toast we tickets just went on sale
yesterday and I just want you to know
it's gonna be nothing like this there
will be straws there will be meat there
will be bottled water and there will be
alcohol I'm sure we work has alcohol too
because all these startups like drink so
much everyone has a bottle of liquor on
their desk
everyone everyone my thing is with the
know meet my mom
I went vegan just to like test it out
for a year and it's changed her life and
that's great she's not gonna press on
somebody else like you can't have me
sure you know like I hate that so you're
telling me somebody somebody could be
anemic they might need a cut of beef
totally and you're you got to bring your
own beef to the party unless is one of
their sponsors like it's one of we works
companies that they're working with a
plant-based company a big vegan right
like josie and the pussycats like
brainwashing machine that's the only
reason why I feel like like yeah what
are their other sponsors no I guess
they'd be their own sponsor I don't know
how anything like that works me neither
but we will be having meat even though I
don't really eat me cuz I only kosher
meat so there's no kosher meat to be
found anywhere right so I'm pretty much
Italian but I would never tell you what
to eat whatever meat or no meat just in
general you know Wendy Williams went
hardcore vegan and then she like got
really sick and they said you need more
meat Wow is that why she fainted on live
TV
yes that was a moment for me I live how
you do and I live for Wendy because she
spills a Deen really keeps it truthful
um yeah she she met with dr. oz a doctor
I was I was like you need a turkey
burger so teach their own you know yes
we over consume everything in the United
States and I when I eat meat especially
since my mom is gonna be can I try and
be really smart about how I get it you
shouldn't be putting crap in your body
we all do it but if I'm gonna choose
between putting vodka in my body and
like a shitty burger I'd rather go vodka
right you know pick your battles and I'm
going for the booze but everyone can
that's your tweets to make you do you
can do it you can't have both - if you
wanted but then like just be careful you
know look at Chrissy Teigen I feel like
she's all she does is eat McDonald's and
she's bangin well I just feel like all
she does is tell us that she's eating
McDonald's I'm not super here for her
like I just feel like she's so extra and
I don't know I don't like what it's
sparked in celebrities have like really
chart like on the one hand I do because
she like brings out the funny normal
version of celebrities but then also
it's like a little try hard for me okay
fair enough I I hear you I see you I
find it very refreshing especially
because she's a model and she's like
look this is what's real I just had my
second baby and I've got stretch marks I
find it very refreshing but I could see
the
extremist right don't like she'll poster
strikes marks after her second baby and
it's like I've had no children and not
have more and makes me feel worse okay
yeah okay but then you know you're
damned if you do damned if you don't
and she's trying to reach out to that
audience me like I'm a girl just like
you but I'm also like Chrissy you're not
just like us you tits are perfect right
if I was gonna get a boob job I would go
into the doctor and I just show Chrissy
I'd be like they're perfect oh I haven't
analyzed them oh honey I've thought I'm
at the.you know the background up my
wallpaper on my phone just they're great
breaths I think I would go for Kate
Upton's
Oh another great another great set of
breasts here's the thing that is like my
boyfriend's his one Hall Pass he loves
Kate Upton loves her that's my one Hall
Pass and we went to the Turks and Caicos
in June in my Hall Pass to look if I was
gonna have a threesome honestly I'm not
really into that I'm not really a person
who shares but I would allow Kate Upton
to show up because I really feel like
I'm just like a thicker version I mean
big boobs blonde hair but we went on
vacation like three days after her in
the Turks and Caicos and Jeff was
devastated he was like we've missed her
by 72 like pump your brakes I mean he
almost like changed the flight stick it
down there like what are you gonna do go
up to Kate Upton and just like with a
boner yeah like that's embarrassing yeah
and now she's pregnant which is so crazy
yes I love her do you like she leads
like a relatively normal life you forget
she's pretty young isn't she like 22
she's 25 Wow
we're the same age and she's like
married to Justin Verlander no pregnant
and where do they live they live like in
Houston right they live in Houston and
they they have a place in the city the
dream the dream anyways they didn't
final story before we're taking all your
questions for Heather oh my god it is
already so late but it's fine it's so
much fun
hope you don't have a hard stop I don't
have a hard out I'm just gonna literally
go back to Lord and Taylor after this I
have some more shopping to do to be
sponsored by them okay you really should
be Starbucks is introducing a new menu
item notch pasta Shiraz but kombucha so
they're really going like hard on this
organic like they're really playing to
this audience that must be their
demographic though like people who don't
use plastic
and drink kombucha I love kombucha and
my mom I love it it's very refreshing
however I did a little bit more research
on it and it really does have so much
sugar in it so I had a nutritionist once
tell me she's like look kombucha is
great and it does have all these
benefits but it's essentially fermented
tea okay it's like slightly so you might
as well just have a glass of wine and
get the antioxidants if you're gonna if
you're gonna talk about like picking
something healthier you might as well
have a glass of rose and call it a damn
day I never even knew what kombucha was
but you know how we have cold beer on
tap here there's the other lever is
kombucha right so I never even smelled
it like it smells like soy sauce it's
the crazy I can't even like matcha
you're either on board or all I'm yeah
I'm not in that family of leverage of
New Age beverages it's got a lot of
probiotics I swear to God probiotics
will save the world I feel like any time
I go to the doctor any time I talk to
anybody health-related they're like can
we talk about your probiotics can we
talk about your good gut flora you take
probiotics do I take a probiotic and
I've never cried more so I've never
taken one but I've been meaning to you
know I'm almost there and I've heard
really good things like from not just
like doctors but from people who are
like it makes me so regular and blah
blah blah and but it takes like a couple
months to start working I feel it up
right away so you know why did you feel
you know try not to [ __ ] my pants it
cost about Tuesday so that's just me
living my truth yeah having a Real
Housewives of New York moment they
talked about too much [ __ ] I agree and
this past week's episode when they got
back to New York they're talking about
it like even more everything is like we
get it also Bethenny's backed up because
she only eats endive sheets like endive
and beets and that's it right I mean
it's roughage you think she'd be good
but no but Ramona was saying this is so
gross but she was like saying how she
had her pants after carton and yet she
was like I was just walking and it fell
out of it like I died the fact that they
in the credits they rolled when Ramona
had like the schmear if you will and
then LuAnn saying like I left our
present for them do they not know that
there might no but like I've met like
I've gotten like sacred like sueded
poisoning I've never not been able to
make
the bathroom like okay caddy session
having it fall out of you is it's not
something I've experienced and I hope
that I never do also what was the
consistency I don't even want to go
there because you're having your morning
toast but don't ever do a full glass
like that size of aloe vera juice I'm
just gonna let you know I'm just gonna
leave it there
iti do the AL of shots whenever like I
passing Equinox like once a year well
though they'll do you're right
and I like or do you're wrong the same
yeah just a little a long way a little
cause long need to be drinking more of
them anyways if you're looking for
kombucha you can find it at Starbucks
now because the coffee chain announced
its going to sell its own line
trendy fermented tea Starbucks is
offering six flavors of kombucha under
its evolution juice brand that said the
drinks have started shipping to stores
in select cities why kombucha the
khopesh drink is hot right now because
of its probiotic punch and zinger flavor
sales of the fermented tea totaled 1.2
billion last year skyrocketing rate of
40% Starbucks says consumer interests
also spiked the same amount in 2017 I
mean people want to get the Booch they
want to get the booze they want to get
the boots I'm on board for it I like
having a plethora of drinks I'm thirsty
all the tiger II and some drinks certain
different purposes like yes technically
you need water but they want like like
tasty waters like a shelter a flavored
Seltzer with a knee cap beans so you
need a coffee like there's just so many
different thing I'm all about the
beverages but you know what I am NOT a
fan of Starbucks like from years ago
because I think that what they serve is
just like hot garbage their coffee is so
inconsistent even when it's good it's
not great and like I only like the cold
brew I stopped going there completely
like two years ago and then the straw
thing happened and now this is happening
and just it's clear this over your milk
dog clear two proportions that I am NOT
the Starbucks customer okay you know and
I'm okay with that there's a lot of
things that I'm not the customer for I
actually enjoy their cold brew because I
think it's got that nice chocolatey with
the hint of cinnamon vanilla taste I'd
love to do your commercials even though
they don't do ads but I feel like I
could sell it you know just really have
a moment but you're making it sound
really good
but this is delicious right it's really
great and when you don't have a straw
you don't love it back so you don't get
the shape this is the difference between
yeah straw I know sure although I know
that my lipstick do I have just like a
liner line I know my lipstick people are
always like what what are you wearing
it's good for two minutes and then I eat
it so and I always wonder like I get
lipstick on my teeth I lick it off like
music have calories no but it's got
chemicals so worse actually yep anyways
those are the stories that you need to
know this morning on this fine Friday
before you embark on your weekend and go
to a dinner party and just be the most
informed person there and now we are
gonna take all your questions for
Heather because we have some really
really great ones this has been so fun
by the way I I mean I've been a fan
forever and I'm I just had the best time
thanks for having that thank you for
coming I'm so glad here in New York I'm
so glad this worked out because you're
like we made so many dreams come true my
dream came true and it's everything that
I could have wanted it to be I'm here
for it okay a question we got a lot for
you is I know you are starting a podcast
yes what is going on with the technical
difficulties can we help and what is the
podcast gonna be about so the name of
the podcast is absolutely not because
that's a catchphrase that I use in my
life like absolutely not Karen um I kind
of want it to be a place that's I need
to say lifestyle but where we will have
like an absolutely not of the day where
you can kind of like it's a safe space
to [ __ ] and rant and then we're gonna
talk about positive stuff too being in
my 30s and I went through like a really
interesting life experience oh I lost my
dad two years ago and so for me I just
want this to be a space where we can
talk about everything we're gonna cry
we're gonna laugh we're gonna get horny
I don't know we're gonna figure it out
but I don't know what I did wrong so
I've been like blocked on iTunes I'm
talking to Tammy today in tech support
she's my girl she's helping me okay so
hopefully it'll be up soon yes and I
realize that I should never like
announce something but I learned the
hard way I'm sorry I teased y'all we've
learned the hard way yeah as well you
can't count your chickens before you
know its immense you're still weak
sometimes people need to like know
something in order to prepare for it but
it's just like I just bit off way more
than exit jokes it stinks it's a jinx
and I thought I could be my own sound
engineer my own tech support I thought
your recorded something in your
microphone and then you hit Send and it
uploaded that's far from the truth
the first podcast upload is very
difficult but then it gets like much
easier
it depends what kind of equipment you
have like we when we do podcasts only
episodes like we have like some [ __ ]
from the audio store and like it's good
and easy now but we still have our like
we one time we recorded a whole episode
without an SD card so there you go in
like two hours and I forgot it one time
we heard a whole episode with an SD card
and we put in the computer and there was
nothing there yeah and then we but we
put it back in the machine and it says
it's there so yeah someone's lying I've
done that about 6 times by myself and
people like it's not that it's not that
hard I've watched 45 tutorials I just
spit off way more than I can chew and I
just need an intern so if I'm looking
for an intern if you want to help me you
don't even necessarily have to be in
Atlanta because I'm kind of a gypsy I'm
in LA I'm in New York I'm all over the
map
so just somebody that I could send some
files to and you're like this sounds
great ok we have some really qualified
toasters who are great all over the
country and any of you would like to
intern for Heather where can they find
they submit resumes and submit at the
absolutely not podcast at gmail.com I
mean I tried to get a hotmail but they
should they didn't want me so here we
are so how often is your podcast gonna
come out hopefully weekly we just gotta
get it we get the ball rolling the train
is has to leave the station and I just
feel like I'm an adult I should be able
to figure this out now this is so hard
it's a hard thing so we understand I'm
we're and we'll be patient great and
it's gonna be now that there's so much
hi the greatest podcast on the planet
and it better be yeah how many times you
have to like the worst thing for me it's
like saying something and then having to
say it again so like usually before the
show Claudie and I like don't even talk
now what we're gonna talk about because
like then we waste our jokes and then we
have to like repeat them and act and
like fake laugh yeah and I noticed that
when I it took a couple times for me to
actually like not hate myself not as an
I don't mind hearing my boys cuz I've
done voiceovers forever so I don't mind
I'm not one of those people who's like
oh I hate listening to our boys it just
felt very like self absorbed and tried
and just
there's just it's just extra you know
but then I was like wait a minute I have
important things to say and I y'all have
asked for it and you go to the podcast
or and you like see who has a podcast
these days yeah my dental hygienist has
a damn pot they're like the people need
me right that's what they need you're
gonna talk about gum safety and gum
hygiene every night Janice really has a
podcast she is a whole situation you
know what I always say like okay Kieran
Kieran is my dental hygienist you know
like when you say dental hygienist who's
extra as hell I think of KarenT
from Real Housewives of Miami if you
ever were graced with that franchise oh
honey that arrant yeah I wanted them to
bring Miami back I'm very upset that
they quit that I know I like what how do
you think what what makes them decide
how if they're gonna it's always a
franchise it's already but it must have
been like so bad because like the first
season of Dallas wasn't like a hit but
they gave it a second Alice you can't I
can't did you watch the second season
yeah I did and I'm just still not on
board for any of them and I know that's
awful but I mean you can't do it all you
really can't watch every everything no
and I like honestly who I am inside is a
Dallas Real Housewife my dream is to
just like marry an oil tycoon and just
be on a ranch and you know count cash
and wear Gucci so so that's on my vision
board um so maybe it's like you'll watch
it when you're on it exactly I just
think it's it's to the goal is there but
it just feels like too far of a reach at
this moment in my life I understand well
speaking of your man yes you are with
the Italian stallion yes uh you guys go
working at looking at rings yesterday so
he has a jeweler you know he's a tie-in
it's a whole thing
you like I and I love his jeweler if you
want to know where I got my name double
nameplate HNH jewelry in New York
they're the best people stop me on the
street about this I love a nameplate I
usually wear one every day I had to take
it off yesterday cuz I could em sculpt
on my stomach which is supposed to give
me ABS you have to take your jewelry off
and I forgot to put it back I've been
doing the most I've done CoolSculpting
I'm doing this new thing like a valus
shape or VelaShape I hope I'm
pronouncing it right literally people
are like you want to try this treatment
I'm like great let's try the same and I
was lying on the table the other day and
I was like I really feel like a guinea
pig like am i Heather Dubrow I don't
know
I would I would trade shoes with Heather
Dubrow any
totally can you tell me about cool
school because like I really did it work
here's the thing you don't really get
full results till about I think six to
eight weeks so I did it three weeks ago
where'd you do it um I did it in Atlanta
at about face it Lana my buddy was like
let's be thinking a big you know like
just let's do all of it
it so basically what happens is it
freezes your fat and then you metabolize
it okay so it actually shrinks the fat
cells and I think you like P amount and
then I'm also doing this like ultrasound
thing on my tummy I'm trying all of it
because I had a major thyroid problem
when I hit 30 and I just put on 25
pounds my hair started falling out and
I'm a very active person now I'm very
comfortable in my skin I'm a larger
woman but I love it like whatever even
if I lost 100 pounds tomorrow I'm not
gonna be a size 2 look at these
shoulders I'm ready to move your
furniture for you
so I'm but I'm just like you know what I
want to like just tighten it up a little
bit no totally so we actually started
going to dr. Sharon Jeezy and we found
like she's Ramona's classic surgeon
we're like Ramona looks [ __ ]
incredible at 60 horrible I was like I
won't we want to go where she's going so
we went there in June and that's where I
got my Botox Claudia got like a natural
train lift that she has a whole new chin
and she's obsessed was it was
non-invasive it was I think it was like
a little invasive but also claudia is
like a drama queen about pain like
technically redheads that have the
lowest threshold for pain but like
claudia has the lowest threshold for
okay god I have a very high so high
breast so I feel like for you it might
be painless but then she also had this
instant light bow machine that she's the
only doctor in New York who has it and
all that stuff I'm still like oh it's
stop burning technology you lay under
like a hot lamp it's actually doesn't
touch you like it's so relaxing I bike I
would usually fall asleep it's like
eight minute intervals on each section
of your body so you do six sessions of
that and then you get your measurements
like you really I lost like seven inches
like across all like Wow stomach it was
amazing I highly recommend and then they
got this new M scott machine which like
it's supposed to build abs for you and
like I just did my third session
yesterday and it's so crazy cuz it's
like Oh like isn't it's a walk in the
park is a day at the spa
okay and so all these like contorts your
stomach like because it's building abs
it's like the process of doing like two
thousand sit-ups and it's the weird
feeling in the world like and I actually
like sore from it
do they use like it ultra the circle
type thing and they like put it under a
belt and then it like vibrate not what
I'm doing the other sculpting thing and
I'll all tag all my doctors on Instagram
so if you're in Atlanta and you want to
do this this is the best I'm doing this
like 10-week session where they do like
a shaper where it basically the so I've
done the cool and now I'm adding the
heat so I'm just trying to like shock it
yeah fuse it shock it out of my system
wait so I asked about cool spots I used
to always think that like that's what I
needed to do but then dr. DZ said like
that I should do in silico and I just
trusted her but like I had this like
pouch and I feel like I'm the perfect
candidate for cool spa but I have yet so
I just was curious I did it the first
year it came out was like eight years
ago and I saw a great difference but I'm
not even kidding you I love my
CoolSculpting session and I went and got
like chick-fil-a so now that I'm going
to berries and SoulCycle and you know
get my swerve on I think I'll have much
better results okay and at this point
whatever if you told me like eat cat
litter and roll around in the grass and
it would like shake me up better I'll do
it no literally same it's like the crazy
links that will go to you just to like
not and I'm doing it for me okay Jeff
loves all about it but I'm doing it for
me wait so I cut you off he's speaking
of jazz yes yes we look around
yes so we've been together seven years
but he was just finishing this like grad
school program and trust me people get
so stressed out they're like are you
getting engaged they are you getting
engaged I couldn't even enjoy my
vacations that I've been on like the
that I went to Italy last year when did
the Turks this year like it's it gonna
happen we have our plan he's like pick
out what you want and as soon as you
know that check clears
we're gonna go get it we just have in a
very adult relationship yeah you know he
has asked me to marry him a hundred
times don't worry all he's not going
anywhere
but you know it takes a while to build
exactly what you want
totally jewelers especially you're gonna
be an engineer in grad school right
exactly
how'd you guys meet we met in the city I
moved here right after college and I
went to the University of Mississippi
hotty toddy and my best girlfriend was
the from New York and Mississippi and we
immediately clicked and
she and Jeff grew up together and we met
in the city and we fell in love
immediately
that's so cute my best my favorite
stories that you told on your Instagram
was when you found Britney Spears
tickets on the floor okay so my first
apartment ever was on 33rd right across
from Aston Square Garden okay did you
like living in that location um the
building was insane I moved up at like
the height of the recession in 2009 so I
got to live in an insane luxury building
for pennies because you know people were
like leaving New York and droves
right so I was what I'm there would be
something in Madison Square Garden
literally just pop over and I was just
walking down the street and I found
tickets I think that all of this is
really coming full circle like when I
look back on my life I was built to like
have a Britney moment right so much of
it has been like defined by Britney yes
ages in her career so I'm just walking
down the street and I see the tickets um
I'm just gonna pick him up cuz I was
gonna get tickets for the show that
night but they were like crazy expensive
and she concert which tour was it I
can't remember what I think the circus
oh I went to that show it was when I was
like I this woman needs to stop I was
and I'm not even kidding you they were
like second row pit seeds so I picked
them up and I looked around to see like
did somebody drop them immediately
no God had laid them in my in my track
and so I look around and I'm like okay
now am I being Punk'd like if somebody
is there [ __ ] on them like what is the
deal and I stood there for a solid like
seven and a half minutes but then if
like you find a hundred all our bill
after seven and a half minutes like it's
yours okay agreed and I kind of looked
around and so I took the tickets and we
went I'd had the time of our lives and
I'd had like 45 chardonnays before the
show so I just started chanting
like in anticipation for Britney to come
out go LSU Tigers and the entire Madison
Square Garden started chanting it and
cuz she's from Louisiana and I just
started this and it was just insane
that's insane cuz it's hard to even
start a chant when it's like you know
the usual chant right but everybody it's
hard to start but LSU is easy and I'm
not even an LSU fan cuz I went to Ole
Miss but everybody that's a Square
Garden was screaming go Tigers go in
like a really thick southern accent it
was just a really prideful moment for me
I'm like in New York City in New York
City that's a big deal yeah wow that's
you
and you said like you are the original
influencer that's influence if I've ever
seen it here we are years later and I
and more without straws so you're
welcome America so your mom is on bumble
my mom's on mumble and you are
catfishing her Kathy Qing others from
New York
yes so we put her on match we did all
these different sites and I honestly
feel like I could run a kajillion dollar
business just helping older gentlemen
make their dating profiles
it's insane I'm not even kidding
honestly that's an amazing idea okay
nobody's stealing we just trademark do
yeah its patent pending I'm gonna text
the lawyer okay great um it's insane
when she was on magic and then look
everybody needs love I'm not saying that
you know these guys shoot me on there
three guys were just in the hospital
just with oxygen tanks on in a gown I'm
not making this up go to my highlights
in my Instagram follow the match stories
one guys in screen names like muff-diver
like these guys are savage they don't
care and I feel like women are supposed
to be held to such a higher standard
yeah you know and the thing is my mom
was 11 years older than my dad and they
had the most amazing loving wonderful
relationship my dad was my hero but my
mom's at this point almost three years
out where she wants a date again it
leaves him somebody to like travel with
that have experiences but it's hard out
there
you know she's I she's like 70
you know like Justin 70 yeah 60 so and
she was 11 years old with my dad and
she's like I don't want some guy in his
80s no and then all the guys who were my
father's age bedpans yeah
gross and they right now they either
want the nurse or the purse so my mom's
in this place where she's like I would
like a guy you know in his 60s who's
still young and vibrant but the guys who
are that age one a 22 year old so keep
dreaming
but the Bumble situation I was literally
at lunch yesterday with Japanese just so
used to my crazy and my Jeff look at all
these hotties there's so many better
options up here in New York really I
just think there's a lot more single
guys perhaps that's so interesting
um and if you have a great-uncle who's
like well-to-do a wonderful person loves
the Lord and wants to travel and like
drink 12 bottles of wine DM me because
as you should be in Atlanta though no he
can be wherever I mean I'm gonna be in
New York I'm in LA I'm all over my mom
was to travel
she likes the spark of a long distance
and that's the thing Jeff and I have
been long-distance for the last like
five years and people always ask how do
you do it I'm like it's great I mean
it's because we know it's not permanent
yeah you had like a goal yeah in mind
cause I see yeah
so how often are you in New York um well
we go back and forth because I was
living in LA and then I came back to
Atlanta for a hot second and we fly back
and forth it's great it's like I don't
have to pick up after him no you know
you haven't seen each other in three
weeks so it's still spicy yep great sex
then you put him on a plane and send his
ass home so where do you want it like
like end up living are you more New York
LA Atlanta I love LA I just feel like I
thrived there when I left New York all
my friends were like Heather you're such
a New Yorker you're gonna hate LA I got
out there and it was like just a perfect
amount of crazy for me to just absorb
but we're gonna be in New York for a
couple years and then in a perfect world
I'd have like a mega mansion off West
Paces Ferry in Atlanta Georgia and like
raise my kids there and have my own
production company speaking that into
existence yes because everything else
you've spoken so far it's come true it's
coming to fruition coming to fruition
and the crazy thing is when I was living
in LA and New York everything now shoots
in Atlanta because there's a big tax
incentive for production so everything
that you see on Netflix every show every
movie is shot in Atlanta but it was
funny when I was living in LA
I'd always fly home to Atlanta to shoot
things but then when I got to Atlanta
I'd have to go back out to LA of course
so I think you have to leave for it to
bring you back got it mmm I watched I'm
do you watch trying to see the new
deines I haven't watched on to see the
new season but they actually shot one of
the scenes at my friend's house that big
mega mansion I'm obsessed with the show
and it's based in out like films in
Atlanta and its base there yes and I
feel like it's just like the new Gossip
Girl and I just love watching people
like have problems that I did I don't
you know right this may be too old for
you but my favorite show of all time is
designing women
I don't know it okay Delta Berg Dixie
Carter Annie Potts just gene smart it's
incredible what this is it's about four
interior designers from Atlanta and it
was very progressive for the time that
it came out and it's hysterical it's
like Will & Grace okay
it's just that level of like
savage sarcasm and it was one of the
best shows so in a perfect world I'd be
able to bring that show back and star in
it and so speaking that into existence I
don't know who owns the rights to the
show but I want that to happen I'm gonna
watch that it's the best
speaking of Atlanta it was like big
shows in Atlanta
are you was Zolciak be your main fan I
actually want a look-alike contest as
her in York like eight years ago I went
as her for Halloween and I won this
before she got all the work done and my
mom saw her at a Publix they live kind
of close to where my mom lives and my
mom saw her at Publix gave her my
business card and was like my daughter
looks like you I look like her before
she like God everything sucked out of
her right and I was so mortified my
mom's like I saw a Kim today at Publix
you know so um I wish they'd bring him
back to Atlanta to Atlanta I do and I
love tardy for the party but I just
think Kim stirred the right amount of
soup in that pot yeah of drama
are you Kim or Nene it depends on the
day I really have a moment I got I swore
Nene off I said girl bye after that
whole debacle she had the stand-up
comedy and you know yelling the rape
joke at someone but you know when then I
said I got to forgive I still think
Nene's great for the show and she you
know she's not a stand-up comic Deanna's
and she kind of had to learn the hard
way so you know I forgave her I really
love them both and I just wish more than
anything that they could find a way to
like get back together me but I know
they're both like two they're both in
the stratosphere like and I'll just keep
dreaming another very important question
Carol or Bethany Bethany Bethany um I
think I understood okay I had a recent
fight with one of my best friends and
we're still not speaking and I know it's
a communication thing and we'll get
there and I'm not a person who fights
like I don't fight with people but I had
that moment where I was like I'm I'm I'm
team Bethenny but then sometimes when
you know you're dealing with other women
sometimes people can say that I'm a
little like cold but I think it's just
because I'm I keep it real yeah and
sometimes I am a person who I can dish
it and I can take it but in some
friendships people are so used to
dishing it all the time that when you
like put your foot down you're like I'm
not taking this yeah
they shut down so no I'm team Bethany
team Bethany for a lot of reasons the
fact that Carol is out now just like put
some nail in the coffin like Bethany
done Bethany won the battle and the war
I thought Carol didn't want to be
through the last four seasons well I
mean Carol's just life is just so
interesting and confusing to me because
she's on her high horse like she acts
like she is just you know William
Shakespeare at least also I have a
couple really dear friends who are
big-time interior designers in Atlanta I
want you to Google get on the Googlers
right now
Carol's old couch debacle
she had this insane I think it was like
a Siberian tiger print yes yeah I resign
the show and she like would not get rid
of it
right but here's the thing that is the
most expensive fabric you can get in the
world and she redid the couch and some
like cheap gray linen and interior
designers across the world just wrote
her off there's a whole blog about it
just Google Carol and her like cheetah
print couch was a whole thing oh my
goodness that makes me just like her
even more
yeah and it was like a hundred thousand
dollar couch that she just like you know
redid to make it look like it was from
Pottery Barn get out of here
I can't also look I wanted the on this
past week's episode we saw Ramona's new
Hamptons house we saw Bethenny's new
apartment and it's like these I mean
especially definitely have so much money
in like it like when I decorate my
apartment I mean like my first like a
dull department like got everything
myself it's like couch rug coffee table
TV console like key and it seems like
like their houses are like the same way
and it's so weird they don't have like a
feeling like a homey feeling to them
it's like I literally Ramona ordered
everything in her house from Wayfarer
but then I guess Sonja said she's
staging it to sell it that makes sense
right like Bethenny's house just like
look so elemental I actually like
Bethenny sense of style because I like
very clean and neat I meet you and I
loved her old apartment but there aren't
any like family photos in the house and
that stresses me out I think you can
keep things kind of monochromatic and
keep it very contemporary but you gotta
have that Bush you know she has great
art she does know but she doesn't have
like there's no photos wallpaper like
that why she doesn't have that all over
Shaymin show penis not penis peanuts
face on the show which I totally respect
yeah she's done a really good job of
that yeah while still remaining
interesting cuz most people who don't
show their full lives like at the booth
right I I actually like Bethenny's style
Sonia style stresses me out
stresses me out it's filthy she has no
well once she cleaned up her house like
and the way it looks though it's like I
would never decorate a home like that
but I appreciate that she's just like
committed to the vibe like better
additional I loved Bethenny's old
apartment I just feel like her new
apartment has it doesn't have a lot of
personality okay it's all I'll say okay
it looks like my home looks the same way
but like I'm 25 I don't have a booming
Skinnygirl business yet I'm not a shark
yet you know what she could really add
to that coffee table just to like bring
him you know always needed you know what
it is shouldn't have enough greenery you
always have to have a few plants just
put some cash in a bowl on that coffee
table and let people know that you're
walking into the Skinnygirl Empire yeah
you know I maybe see I should have
started baby fat maybe my new line for
women who are top-heavy will be back fat
but we'll spell at pH 8000 that's pretty
yeah go that's that's something we can
all get behind add it to the board one
more house ice for you that's a bit
dated but I'm just I still felt like so
like I was on the wrong side so I'm just
curious I'm Erica or Teddy Erica all day
every day can I tell you the first thing
that I added to my vision board when I
made it this year was I wanted to be
friends with Erica Jane and I it will
happen it will haven't I feel like she
would love you but did you hear that
she's not coming back I did and I think
her husband isn't doing well I have a
feeling that that might be with it to
have something to do with it well I'm
his older her she literally used the
show to perfection like has been there
that she wants doesn't have to work too
hard but like you I was getting the
Beautyblender campaign money I just want
a creative director right I would love
to say hey team I'm going to CBS got to
pick up some midol and then for you know
four and a half hours later I'm having a
moment
right everyone needs a creative director
in their life I agree have you been
watching The Real Housewives of Orange
County I live for it the oh geez
absolutely okay Nikki verse
Kelly I feel like you would like Vicki
yes it was girl code but I mean it's
Orange County it's so small yes Vicki
should have given her the heads-up a
hundred percent but also Kelly you
weren't awful - Michael Michael was her
ex right yeah she was so awful to him on
the show they clearly didn't like each
other so I think Kelly puts a hard shell
but you can't get mad at Vicki I'm sorry
yes maybe girl code Vicki should have
given her the heads-up but really when
couples break up come on we're adults
here hey you asked for the divorce you
got to let it go I mean I'm so Tina it's
just still so fresh and like oh you're
team Kelly yeah because Michael like can
do whatever he wants that Kelly probably
wouldn't be upset but like for her best
friend to be facilitating Michaels new
relationship going on double dates with
them and then hanging out with Kelly
like you really can't you have to choose
a side in a divorce I imagine yes and
yeah Vicki's trying to play the fence
and like she's so adamant about playing
offense and like she's like she has in
her head like as long as I I'm not
getting in the middle but it's like you
ready you put yourself in the middle so
now you have to mediate I've got in
trouble with this before actually where
I had friends that broke that broke up
and then I still talked to both and they
felt that I had to take a side and I was
like I'm really honestly and truly just
trying to keep the peace so you felt
equally strong friendships with each of
them um I did it was like my best guy
friend and my best girl friend and
there's so much better apart in now they
both got married it's a great thing but
I remember being like I feel like I'm
being shady to both but I'm not you know
I just like really because to me I was
like guys we're all cool I'm the
peacemaker we're all great but I didn't
realize that it actually really made
them both upset so you know no I had to
pick a side so interesting yeah and then
what do you think about the new girls
this is what I think snooze it's just so
weird how like they all have this like
robust friendship like popping off
Mexico this that and then like Vicki and
Jeana is her name go on and walk
together and they discovered that
jeana's the same age as Vicki's daughter
like that's it great that's it
that does not be a housewife make and is
Jeana is the brunette no Jean Jeana is
the blonde but you would think the
brunettes name would be Jeana she gives
us such Jeana buys such Jeana boobs
her name is Emily okay he calls her
Jessie because she looks like Jesse from
The Parent Trap
she does
does so she's just Jessie okay she is
chessy um she's trying to have another
baby but like clearly is in over her
head and the other girls in over her
head they just you know they're they're
young moms and I think they're just like
exhausted which all my girlfriend's are
having kids now and shout out to all the
moms doing the most out there y'all are
just incredible but I just think they're
gonna be exhausted after like episode 3
they're just gonna say I can't and I
think it's just like too much to bring
in such new people who really don't have
established friendships with the women
because they have been through so much
together they're better off like I think
that the intention with bringing back
what was Lydia even though I did not
like her I appreciated the intention of
bringing back an old housewife who knows
these girls but I need some Alexis
Bellino is what's gonna shake things up
Alexis Bellino is another one whose
Instagram I actually think we need to
save Alexis as well oh she's going
through that really intense divorce has
been she's been putting up kind of
cryptic messages you know it's been very
interesting right so this is the time to
bring her back this is exactly the time
to bring her back we need to call in and
we always need to bring back Heather oh
no one no one will fill the role that
Heather did which was just like moral
high-ground yeah insane wealth yeah
perfect life and that's the aspirational
house map aspect of Real Housewives
which I think are encountered
yes I would actually out of all of the
different seasons that you could be on I
would be afraid to be honest II I just
feel like trying to get into that Tamra
Vicki there's always somebody who draw
you know drives a wedge and they are so
savage together or apart I would I feel
like I can handle myself in a lot of
situations but they would probably eat
me alive yeah except like I love Shannon
beador
I love Sheena Midori her Fung Shui of
her house you know I'm into supplements
and like I'm not into crystals but
whatever if you need a crystal to like
cleanse your life but she is so open
with her level of that [ __ ] crazy I'm so
on board she's so open about everything
and I think like she's someone who
people really like can relate to yes and
I just think she's like so brave and
also just so cool and a great mom and
like a great housewife and she loved her
doing it all before I let you go this
has been the longest show of all time
the Britney challenge
I think that I've never tried it but I
feel like I could be an a cause it
doesn't look that hard I have a pony
somewhere and I would love for you to do
the Brittany challenge I don't know how
it's gonna work if we stand up
yeah sure would you like a look us like
a slight seated one yes we could like
happen so I don't have a hair thing but
basically for the Brittany challenges
you're just trying to like do the most
in the least at the same time phoning it
in with a little bit she adjust her
ponytail a lot she does this where she's
like like doing it's like it's like
rolling the day roll yes like snake eyes
so blow on it first and then a little
snake eyes so it's just kind of like you
know you just kind of move the shoulders
you tug up a lot you adjust the pony and
kind of look off like look up to there
just yeah in toxic unzip in under and a
lot of shoulder rolls okay that felt I
think I felt like her yeah yeah Wow so
you know we're doing it all and it's
just so funny when like enews her post
her repost her video of her dancing like
this is everything Brittany still got it
and it's like this is sad and Brittany
does not still have it
I really never wanted to speak on it I
would just kind of be like okay guys you
see what I'm saying but if you look at
the Instagram from her European tour
right now the European fans are just
nearby island they're Wyland they're
upset they're very upset so I'll let
them take that okay well I'm so glad you
did speak on it because that's how I was
introduced to your a body of work which
has changed my life and better your
that's how you are on the toast this
episode has been so much fun thank you
so much for joining us for having me
toasters y'all are the best I kept you
so overtime and I'm so sorry but like
premium content there's no there's no
time limit isn't that the truth that's
going on a pillow that's gonna go and my
guest bed one day yes in dreams
anyways have a great weekend everyone
we'll be back on Monday camp toast
tickets are live Lincoln bio on our
Instagram page the password is premium
all caps see there we're so excited
it'll be nothing like camp we work bye
you